so would people be in here during
hurricane Florence they could be they
could be depending on how the hurricane
goes certainly the FBI has a role to
play in helping in a hurricane in
hurricane Harvey for example or
hurricane in Puerto Rico both you know
we had significant presence trying to
help in a variety of ways in Houston for
example there was an agent that I'd met
who took out his boat and went out and
rescued you know a family of 12 and
another one who went and rescued a woman
whose child was in a wheelchair in
Puerto Rico our folks took additional
steps they were out essentially
delivering water helping clear spaces
incredible bond with the community there
and what was really striking to me was
that in the Puerto Rico office in our
San Juan office even as they were still
picking up the pieces and helping that
community recover from the havoc there
were they did a 104 person gang takedown
they obviously had helped for a while in
the midst of the hurricane clean up in
the aftermath of the hurricane and it
just shows the FBI's commitment to
trying to do the mission no matter what
the circumstances